Having said that let's make some noise for your headliner.
The guy who came to see, are you guys ready? Yes, let's get it going.
You seen him on cone and he's seen him tonight. Show Netflix all over. Please.
Welcome stage. Very funny, Mr. Mark Norman.
Hey comedy. Huh?
We're really doing it. Oh boy. This is wild.
I've been off 86 days now. I'm back and uh,
I don't know how I ever did this. This is terrifying.
I just got nothing but swastikas here, so I don't know what to do, but, uh,
just to Canadian, tell him jokes. Bear with me folks. Uh,
I am rusty. Uh, I'm nervous, but we're going to have fun. You know,
it's been a, it's been a while, but we'll be, there'll be bad. All right.
All right, me take it easy. That's nice. Built a little, make a wishy, but I'm
good to be here. And then the Dallas, what a town, huh? It's hot, hot, fun,
fun. I might not. I'm coming from New York, you know? Um,
my whole cities of garbage fire right now. Uh,
it's the epicenter of Corona. We got riots and feels like the sixties,
race riots.
We just went to space and the president has a headshot.
It feels weird to do in Dallas, but um,
yeah, I know it used to be cool to be from New York.
Like, I'd go to cities. They were like,
thanks for coming here from New York all the way now people are like,
thanks for, uh, you know, getting my grandma's sick. Your piece of garbage,
but we'll have fun. A lot of jokes, a lot of. Bear with me.
There's a lot of crap here, but you guys are living the good life. You know,
everything's locked up in New York. I went to a restaurant today.
I feel like an Amish guy. I'm like, Whoa, lights. Look at this. Holy.
Uh, I got my hair cut in the backyard last week. I'm a, I'm a mess. All right.
How you doing? Hey, you look familiar. Eh, all right. Um,
that's always a bad sign when I know every one of my fans by face.
Alright cool. Yeah. All right, here we go. Corona jokes. What,
what a time we're living in. I, I hope we get the antibody test. I don't know.
Who knows. You know, it was probably immune to this is a, the two girls,
one cup chicks. I feel like, uh, I feel like they're going to be fine. You know,
those girls can take a licking. Um, ah,
just so I'm rusty in every way. I'm out of shape. You guys have gyms yet.
Are those open? Wow.
You guys are bananas. Holy hell. Good for you. Yeah.
You got the gym. Why don't we don't have any gyms up there.
I'm all mushy and gay, you know, I'm uh, yeah,
I am out of shape. I haven't been this out of shape since, uh,
the gyms were open, you know, uh, things are tough. Yeah. But I mean,
it's business as usual, I'm paying for a gym membership and not going.
So nothing's really that different, but uh, yeah, working on it,
you gotta wear your mask. Now everybody's got the mask. Let's be honest.
Some people need a muzzle. Jesus Christ. Yet the hell up, stop yelling at me.
You know, Corona is so weird. It's like a horror movie. Like, ah,
if you're out at the Ozarks at the pool, you're evil. You're going to get it.
But if you're protesting, you'll be all right. Like what's the difference?
It's like the disease knows you're doing good or not. You know,
it's all very cookie. And now we're just sitting at home,
watching Netflix for six months, you know? Like, everybody's like,
what are you watching? I'm watching my life. Pass me by. Die in here.
Brutal. Everything's weird. Now our strip clubs open here.
Really? So do the chicks have no clothes on,
but are wearing a mask that seems weird. Like, Hey, here's a sloppy 20.
I'll put my nose in your butt hole, but don't cough on me. What are you crazy?
Everything's backwards.
But I'm lucky to be here. This is a great gig is a great club. And uh,
next week I'm playing a target Minneapolis. So, uh,
that could go either way, you know? Yeah. So thanks for having me. Um,
people are getting angry. This is everybody's pent up. Everybody's worked up,
you know, some people are mad at Asian people. Asian people love the riots.
They're like, woo. It's off us for a minute. You, Jesus Christ. Yeah.
I saw a bunch of people online are saying racist to Asian people. I'm like,
look, if you're going to type a bunch of race and to Asian people,
don't do it from an iPhone. All right.
Have some respect for the kid who made it.
All right. Oh, that's going to get a lot worse.
Um, buckle up books, all words. We're all gonna die. One day. Woo.
I mean, this is a tough time in history for black people.
Black people are going through it.
The two people have a tough right now where black people and women named Karen,
they were having a tough go. Um, but yeah. Yeah.
Bore black women there they're there. Yeah. They got hit hard by the disease.
You know, which I'm shocked by because black blue is so strong. I'm surprised.
I thought they'd be fine with illness. I mean, look at magic Johnson.
He's still kicking. Right. He's doing great. Hell he beat Coby.
[Inaudible].
I know who saw that coming.
Yeah. You got to live life folks. Yeah.
I know. Uh, black people are getting sick.
I blame institutionalized racism and elaborate handshakes. Come on.
Those things, uh, all this that had to catch up at some point, you know?
Right. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah.
I felt horrible. And I saw what happened in Minneapolis, the REITs out there.
I got be, I didn't know. There were black people in Minnesota. I had no idea.
I've been, I've been there like 10 times I've ever seen one black person. Um,
but you know, everybody wanted their business reopened. Well,
the looters did that. They just did it through the glass, you know, but uh,
they were open. Hey, here we.
Go.
Uh huh. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
Fun times. Weird times. You know,
they interviewed R Kelly about it and he was like, COVID-19 too old for me.
But um, yeah. Uh, boy, I hate myself.
Uh, I don't know what's going on. The whole country is nuts.
Jimmy Fallon got in trouble for blackface. Like, like what are we doing?
That was 20 years ago. Why are we mad at Jimmy found the TV show, put it out,
NBC approved it. There was a writers' room. Why is it was 20 years ago?
You know what I was doing 20 years ago, I was banging a 16 year old.
You can't judge stuff. By the later date, I was, I was also 16,
20 years ago. If you didn't don't call the police or blog or whatever.
Right. I think we're all sick of this though. We're all. I mean,
Corona is kind of like the check engine light, you know,
when you first hear about it, you're like, this is terrifying.
Then after a while you're like, I gotta get to work.
This is too much. Yeah.
Some people didn't buy it though. My uncle, he looks at Corona,
like it's the tooth. Fairy's like, I know this is all made up,
but I'll take the free money.
Mm mm mm.
It's a crazy country. We live in, you know, eventually all this will be over,
you know, it's something to look forward to. Eventually this will all be over.
You know, the pandemic will end.
The police brutality will end and then we'll be right back to school shootings.
You know what a, what a nation,
these poor kids that got to go to school at home.
Now they've got to have homeschooling every kid.
How long till a teacher in Florida one of her students. Ah.
Cybersex.
Though cyber sex. Oh, I that up.
I thought you guys would be wearing masks. This is nice to see, you know,
there's so many masses. I hate the mask. I can't,
I can't tell which women need to be smiling. Yeah.
Okay.
Oh right. Yeah. Things have gotten crazy.
And then we got a big election coming up, big election coming up. Uh,
I think I'm going to vote for Biden, but I don't know anything about the guy.
All I know is it feels like the guy's running an entire presidential campaign on
having a cool black friend.
It seems like all I know about him and he was like kind of a creepo old dude,
you know, if he's wearing a mask,
how's he going to smell those little girl's hair? How's that going to work out?
Louis CK donate a bunch of money to Biden and Biden said, no, thanks.
I was like, what? He's like, he's a creep. Like, yeah. But so are you,
You're not going to take his money. What about you? Huh?
That's like Chris Brown going. I can't watch MMA. You know? That's great. Yeah.
I can't do it. Yeah. It's too bad. That's violent, you know?
Mm.
Yeah. Joe Biden. What a kook. I can't wait till he meets Greta Thornburgh.
Can we get those two together? You know, have him creep out on her. You know,
he hugs her for too long. He's like, is it global warming or is it hot in here?
Uh she's like, how dare you?
Alright. I think we've had enough of that. Um, Ooh, baby doll.
That was a, it comes right back. I mean 85 plus days out,
whatever it's been. It just, I was nervous and it's like a,
I hate to use the old cliche. It's like riding a bike.
You just get up there and you're like, Oh, peddling again.
And then you noticed like, Oh, I'm doing it. And then you get scared.
Then you just go, Hey, don't even think about it. And just,
just sit back in the water. I would never have taken that much time off.
I was forced to take time off as we all are.
And it may make you appreciate, I do this every weekend. Hey,
we became like autopilot.
And then to go back up there after 80 days and be like, Oh my God,
this is so amazing. What I'm doing.
I wrote this and they're laughing and it's flowing and the lights and the crowd
and beautiful thing. I'm getting sappy and queasy up here. But, uh,
it's going to be bad. Yeah.